und meine kollegin katharina kühn
beobachtet für uns den tag nach der wahl
bei der fdp katharina in dieser sitzung
geht man vermutlich bester laune oder
ja die laune hier die ist ziemlich gut
die fraktion hat ja nun auch 92
abgeordneten der vergangenen
legislaturperiode waren ist 80 aber wie
hier die stimmung ist das können wir
einen aus der fraktion direkt fragen
constantin coole ist bei mir einerseits
mitglied im bundesvorstand aber vor
allen dingen auch in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode innenpolitischer
sprecher gewesen herr coole hier stehen
ein paar formalia an aber wird ist nicht
im größten teil um das wahlergebnis und
unmögliche sondierungen gehen also jetzt
freuen wir uns erstmal das so eine große
fdp fraktion wieder im deutschen
bundestag vertreten ist es wird heute
eine kurze tagesordnung geben mit einer
aussprache zum vergangenen wochenende
wir werden christian lindner wieder
bestätigen als fraktionsvorsitzenden
davon ist auszugehen also mir sind keine
anderen kandidaturen bekannt und er hat
ja als spitzenkandidat wirklichen tollen
wahlkampf gemacht und wird deswegen
wahrscheinlich mit einem sehr guten
ergebnis heute wieder gewählt und dann
gibt es einige formalien die noch
geklärt werden müssen mit blick auf die
gespräche die jetzt anstehen und
insofern wird es eine spannende sitzung
und ein schönes wiedersehen mit vielen
kolleginnen und kollegen sie waren ja
heute morgen auch beim treffen des
bundesvorstands dabei und da wurde unter
anderem gesagt dass man jetzt vor
sondierungsgespräche mit den grünen
führen möchte was erwarten sie sich denn
davon wir haben gestern gesehen dass
sich das parteiensystem in deutschland
fundamental verändert zwei parteien die
in der vergangenheit über 40 prozent
gehabt haben nämlich die spd und die
union kommen jetzt nicht mal mehr auf
ein viertel oder um ein viertel der
wählerstimmen und wenn man die
wahlergebnisse von grünen und fdp
zusammen nimmt dann ist das über ein
viertel sind also stärker als die spd
oder die union und gerade diesen beiden
parteien der union und der spd ist es in
der vergangenheit immer leichtgefallen
kleinere koalitionspartner gegeneinander
auszuspielen und das darf nicht mehr
sein in einem veränderten parteiensystem
wir wollen jetzt mal gucken ob man sich
mit dem grünen auf ein paar punkte
verständigen kann die inhaltlich wichtig
sind für das land und ob wir uns auf ein
format verständigen können auf welcher
weise jetzt koalitionsgespräche oder
sondierungsgespräche stattfinden einfach
damit die augenhöhe und der gegenseitige
respekt gewahrt ist sie sprechen jetzt
schon die art und weise an sie waren
2017 jahr auch dabei bei den
sondierungsgesprächen was erwarten sie
was wird diesmal anders laufen auch von
fdp seite aus die gespräche die vor uns
liegen vor allen demokratischen parteien
werden schon deswegen ganz anders
ablaufen weil angela merkel nicht mehr
teil dieser gespräche ist und man muss
glaube ich vor der lebensleistung von
angela merkel den hut ziehen das ist
auch etwas wo man mit respekt dem ganzen
gegenübersteht gleichzeitig gab es aber
keine bewegung mehr in denen sondierungs
und koalitionsgespräche 2017 und man
musste gerade als kleinerer partner das
gefühl haben dass wir berechtigte
anliegen unter den teppich gekehrt
werden sollen und es ist zu erwarten
dass jetzt bei gesprächen im jahr 2021
das anders läuft das ist keiner der
schon erfahrungen aus der regierung mit
bringt die union sicherlich strukturell
aber die grünen und die fdp kommen
möglicherweise neu in eine solche
konstellation und deswegen wird es vom
sound vom gegenseitigen miteinander her
anders werden sie kennen ja auch viele
von den grünen eben durch die vergangene
legislaturperiode
fdp und grünen hat ja auch mal
zusammengearbeitet stichwort wahlreform
was versprechen sie sich denn von diesen
erfahrungen die sie bereits gemacht
haben in einem parlament wo es auch
politische extreme gibt in einer
parteienlandschaft die immer diverser
wird müssen demokratische parteien sich
nicht aneinander annähern wohl aber
respektvoll miteinander kooperieren
können und wir haben gesehen dass die
große koalition ist nicht hinbekommen
hat den bundestag zu verkleinern im
gegenteil erst noch größer geworden wir
haben gesehen dass die
parteienfinanzierung angepasst wurde
haben gesehen dass an verschiedenen
stellen auch die rechte der opposition
und des parlaments gerade auch während
der korona krise geschlossen worden sind
und bei all diesen fragen gab es ein
respektvolles miteinander mit dem grünen
weil uns schlichtweg das interesse
geeint hat ein wort mitzureden an den
entscheidungen die hier im parlament
getroffen werden und deswegen ist das
eine gute grundlage für die gespräche
die jetzt vor uns liegen sie wissen
jetzt hier gleich rein in die
fraktionssitzung und dann kann ich sie
vielleicht schon eher kurzen antwort
bewegen was glauben sie denn gibt es
schon irgendwelche anzeigen ob es eher
jamaika oder ampel wird also mit dem
gestrigen wahlergebnis ist jamaika
wahrscheinlicher geworden als es in den
wochen vorher war aber ob das auch dazu
führt dass jamaika wahrscheinlicher ist
als eine ampel das kann man zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht sagen konzert die
kohle vielen dank viel spaß jetzt bei
der ersten 17 und das war es dann erst
einmal hier von uns von der
fraktionsebene übrigens vor dem saal
sitzungssaal der unionsfraktion denn
auch die fdp muss sich an corona regeln
halten und deswegen muss man hier in
einen größeren raum tragen als man das
normalerweise macht und damit zurück
nach bonn ins studio